voilà pourquoi mon mandat sera guidée
par deux exigences la première sera de
rendre aux français
cette confiance en eux depuis trop
longtemps affaibli
oh je vous rassure je n'ai pas pensé une
seule seconde qu'elle se resterait comme
par magie le soir du 7 mai ce sera un
travail lent exigeant mais indispensable
il m'appartiendra de convaincre les
françaises et les français que notre
pays qui aujourd'hui semble mise à mal
par les vents parfois contraire du cours
du monde porte en son sein toutes les
ressources pour figurer au premier rang
des nations
je convaincrai nos compatriotes que la
puissance de la france n'est pas
déclinantes
mais que nous sommes à l'orée d'une
extraordinaire renaissance parce que
nous tenons entre nos mains tous les
atouts qui feront et qui font les
grandes puissances du 21e siècle
pour cela je ne céderai sur rien des
engagements pris vis-à-vis des français
tous ceux qui concourent à la vigueur de
la france et à sa prospérité sera mise
en oeuvre
le travail sera libéré les entreprises
seront soutenus l'initiative sera
encouragé la culture et l'éducation par
lesquels se construit l'émancipation la
création et l'innovation seront au coeur
de mon action les françaises et les
français qui se sentent oubliés par ce
vaste mouvement du monde vont se voir
mieux protéger tout ce qui forge notre
solidarité nationale sera refonder
réinventer fortifiée l'égalité face aux
accidents de la vie sera renforcée tout
ce qui fait de la france un pays sûr où
l'on peut vivre sans avoir peur sera
amplifié la laïcité républicaine sera
défendue
nos forces de l'ordre notre
renseignement nos armes et réconfortés
l'europe dont nous avons besoin sera
refonder relancer car elle nous protège
et nous permet de porter dans le monde
nos valeurs nos institutions
décrié par certains doivent retrouver
aux yeux des français l'efficacité qui
en a garanti la pérennité car je crois
aux institutions de la vème république
et ferait tout ce qui est en mon pouvoir
pour qu'elle fonctionne selon l'esprit
qui les a fait naître pour cela je
veillerai à ce que notre pays connaisse
un regain de vitalité démocratique
les citoyens auront voix au chapitre ils
seront écoutés dans ce combat
j'aurai besoin de chacun la
responsabilité de toutes les élites
politiques économiques sociales
religieuses de tous les corps constitués
de la nation française sera appelé
nous ne pouvons plus nous réfugier
derrière des usages ou des habitudes
parfois hors du temps nous devons
retrouver le sens profond
la dignité de ceux qui aujourd'hui nous
rassemble agir de manière juste et
efficace pour notre peuple
la france mais forte que si elle est
prospère
la france n'est un modèle pour le monde
que si elle est exemplaire et c'est là
ma seconde exigence parce que nous
aurons rendu aux français le goût de
l'avenir et la fierté de ce qu'ils sont
le monde entier sera attentif à la
parole de la france parce que nous
aurons su dépasser ensemble nos craintes
de nos angoisses nous donneront ensemble
l'exemple d'un peuple sachant infirmer
ses valeurs et ses principes qui sont
ceux de la démocratie et de la
république